now when you buy Sonic mania collector's  edition you get the Sonic mania  collector's edition statue absolutely  free alone on a Friday night no problem  Sonic mania collector's edition handles  stubborn stains it even comes with a  gold ring for that special someone in  your life she said yes Congrats you too  but wait it comes with a game to to get  Sonic mania just log onto the world wide  web download and play Sonic mania  collector's edition easily holds any  tackle box made from a space-age polymer  cardboard four years of family fun Sonic  mania is humanely raised free-range and  organic and chefs love it too  look at that sizzle by the Sonic midea  collector's edition for the ultimate  celebration of past and future Sonic  mania collector's edition available now  for a limited time only  egghead sold separately  [Music]